he'll come off the pick trying to get
there
step back lonzo
[Music]
we've got to close the gap
from offense to defense the offense has
been fine as lonzo ball
nails a buzzer beating three to make it
71-66
that wasn't a bad pass either as lonzo
flashed by him he challenged him a
little bit he's got jackson in the lob
boy how tough was that finish yes
it's nice to see jackson get going who's
his size and his strength against you
you make him run this is what you do you
run the floor
and you finish they'll be able to score
but can they get stops and lonzo beat
the clock
four seconds left marshall driving
finding ball gets rid of it in time
it's good lonzo fall with a big three
before halftime
to give new orleans a little momentum
currently stands
in the western conference and also a
preview of game two of our
doubleheader tonight with the nuggets
and lakers
alonso ball answers right back that's
his eighth three tonight
that's a career high for him tim rolls
by the way four and six this year in one
possession games
bridges came into the game he's
averaging a career best this year he's
hit 40 percent of his three
see this is what i mean yeah you got to
look who's that
and this is our energy power play it
started early you could see the mismatch
when it
because you see deandre ayton's out
there on lonzo if de'andre aiden is out
there on lonzo
who do they have on zion timeout's not
an issue for either team
lonzo ball leaves it for hayes the ball
brothers doing it on their offensive end
[Music]
he'll come off the pick trying to get
there
step back lonzo what up to 100. put
those two in the pick-and-roll
and lonzo up to 29 with the bucket
that's tough
that's tough snatch back
badge goes to lonzo
[Music]
after that loss on friday night at home
against phoenix imploring his guys to
make the necessary changes defensively
like that
and pay attention to detail at the
defensive end lonzo ball
got the message
out of the timeout ball works that
dribble gets to the rim scoops and
scores
nice job by lonzo ball you see this
they're not collapsing
dangle collapse they're going to say you
know what finish over sadiq bay so you
know what you tell them lonzo i will